[Music]
6 22 easter sunday is this weekend the
easter bunny
always brings baskets full of sweets and
other goodies but they can be really
harmful
even deadly to your cat or dog
petrindologist charlotte reed talks
about
how to have a safe holiday with your
pets
i think it's always great to have your
dog dressed for the photo
op so he can be a bunny the new costume
is the peeps
and hammy likes wearing his little bunny
costume
but one of the big holiday dangers is
you if you want to dress your pet in a
costume
you want to make sure he's comfortable
he's not stressed and if you do have a
pet that doesn't like costumes
consider a bandana because you don't
want to start easter off
on a bad foot but you want to have a
nice photo op maybe you and your pet so
that's always a good thing
okay now i know you're a chocoholic
right well sort of yeah okay
well you're not but i am and one of the
biggest dangers that the aspca hotline
receives
not only for halloween and valentine's
day and christmas but also easter is
chocolate
chocolate contains caffeine and
theobromine which can call
upset rapid heart rate vomiting i mean
and cats particularly do not have
like sweet taste buds like dogs do but
they are
attracted to the shiny foil that you can
see like this chocolate bunny here
and they can eat the chocolate foil
causing intestinal blockage
as well as the strength so a lot of
times your your petal
will sneak off and maybe chew or nibble
on some of those chocolate treats or
maybe like that beautiful lily that
you've got there how do you know
if they're exhibiting symptoms of
something after they've ingested a no-no
like that
well you know one of the greatest things
to do especially if you're a household
full of kids because a lot of people
celebrate easter with their children
whether they're making easter baskets or
going to church
you want to be careful about what you do
you want to tell your kids before the
holiday comes up
we can't give our pet any of the good
chocolate goodies or anything in the
basket
we have to be careful when we're easter
egg hunting the other thing is and the
reason i bought lilies and tulips
is because lilies are especially
dangerous to cats and many people have
cats
almost three times as many people in
this country have cats versus dogs
and even if they inhale the lily pollen
or they chew it cats can have renal
failure
now with tulips and hyacinths dogs like
to
not you know dig them up sometimes
people have them
in a plant on the table then they go and
they plant them in a garden
but a lot of times the dogs will dig up
the bulbs
because they'll smell the sweet smell
and they'll like it but then they'll
chew on the bulbs and the bulbs can be
deadly a lot of times with dogs
you'll see gi problems diarrhea vomiting
so really it's a great idea not to put
bulbs in the ground unless you have an
area that's
not away from your dog and if you have a
cat just keep the lilies out of the
house
charlotte all also warned against buying
bunnies as pets for easter because a lot
of times
they end up in the shelter as soon as
just a couple of three weeks later
because bunnies start out
cute and little and then they get much
bigger and people don't really know what
to do with them
yep and they dig yeah it's important to
make sure you're safe when you've got
the little easter egg hunts going on
around the house so good stuff there
from charlotte and sherry appreciate
that it